there was a big Premiere in London for
Star Trek beyond that is Captain Kirk
himself right there Chris Pine giving a
huge thrill to the hunters of fans who
turned out I know they love that
absolutely you know who else loves it
the franchise I'm talking about Rihanna
of course huge fan of the franchise
ruthy's all over the place today she's
in this story too as we bring you
exclusive footage from the set of the
new Star Trek Adventure Star Trek has
been a part of my life since I was a
little girl my dad really is the one who
introduced me to Star Trek it just took
me one episode to fall in love with this
other world that I couldn't understand
but I felt like I could relate to I hit
a wall Rihanna transformed and used
elements from the film for her video for
Sledgehammer the theme song for Star
Trek Beyond
besides swarm ships and floating rocks
here's what else to expect from the
summer blockbuster
high octane action
brand new aliens and one of the hottest
cash you'll see this summer
and we caught up with them during
filming it's a good choice ET is first
on the set of Star Trek Beyond who's the
captain now it's been nearly a decade
since the first movie but this group is
aging like fine wine
there's plenty of fun and plenty of love
we really have grown to love one another
I literally feel like we are morphing
into the original cast there was only
one issue so he couldn't be here today
one of the twins is sick would you ever
go by do a little babysitting too help
her yeah it's family man yeah sure I'll
babysit I'm not that great with kids but
I can sing a song you can help out yeah
sure